joining me now is ben domenic co-founder
and publisher of the federalist and a
fox news contributor also with me tom
bevin co-founder and president of real
clear politics tom
now this didn't just happen
because of afghanistan
you get the sense that americans are
just finally waking up to the fact that
biden doesn't seem oftentimes to have
any idea of where he is or what he's
doing
yeah no that's right i mean he's been
dealing with multiple crises from uh you
know the immigration
situation at the border to inflation to
crime etc but i do think afghanistan was
the moment where
the myth was exploded that that one was
one of joe biden's cornerstone of his
campaign that he was you know his
experience and competence that adults
were back in charge i mean that is gone
now and the other thing that i think
that happened is one of the intangibles
is that it's taken a bite out of his
credibility he promised the american
people he would always tell us the truth
good bad or otherwise and he's been
shown to to not be being square with the
american people he's been contradicted
by members of his own administration by
reports on the ground and so i think for
those two reasons afghanistan has really
hurt him and really
accelerated uh the decline that was sort
of already underway
and msnbc ban was doing well its best
damage control for the white house today
watch
this was certainly not the august this
administration had hoped for and they
certainly had hoped to go into september
really being able to focus on their
domestic policy agenda administration
officials believe if they can keep the
focus if they can keep the organization
and the discipline they will be able to
manage the domestic agenda the foreign
policy agenda they want while also being
able to handle whatever else comes their
way
ben
you hear commentators and uh political
folks on the left saying well this is a
situation
they can manage themselves out of do you
think that's accurate
well they're they're practically
screaming not good joe
i mean and in fact the thing that you
know is really going on here laura and
you know this is that it's not so much
motivated by all the bad things that are
happening it's that joe's making them
look bad it's like we vouched for you we
said you were competent we said that you
were compassionate we said that you were
an adult in the room we said that you
were able able to manage the government
in the way that uh president trump was
not we went out there we got out over
our skis saying you know during this
pandemic weird campaign where you were
completely hidden from the voters oh no
you can trust in joe and now they're
looking around and saying joe you're
making us look bad you know we promised
that you were going to be good and now
factor after factor is going against him
and and one more thing about this
it's not ideological in the sense that
like you can you can have an ideological
critique of what's going on at the
border but really it's a competence
critique you can have an ideological
critique of the decisions about
afghanistan but really it's can you do
your job and i think that americans are
waking up to the fact that joe biden
really can't and he doesn't seem to be
really aware or or willing to
acknowledge when he fails at his job
well tom
the white house economic adviser this
guy brian deese
wants people to kind of
i think try to deny what we're seeing
what larry summers has acknowledged for
many months which is this impending doom
of growing inflation watch
about half of the overall increase in
grocery prices can be attributed to
a significant increase in prices in
three products in
beef in pork and in poultry if you take
out those three categories we've
actually seen inc price increases that
are more in line with historical norms
tom isn't everything trucked
that gas is involved in since it's
doubled in price
i mean we've all gone to the grocery
stores like orange juice eggs milk
everything
but will that will that line work
no i don't think telling people that you
know if they just don't eat hamburgers
or chicken sandwiches that's gonna
that's gonna make things better look
there's a you got pulled out this week
to show that 44 of americans that what
they look to is the indicator for
whether the economy is good or not it's
not the stock market it is what it costs
for them at the kitchen table what it
costs to put food on the table and as
people are looking around they are
seeing these rising prices i would also
say back to ben's point in addition to
the competence issue i mean one of the
problems for the bite administration is
many of these crises are self-created
self-inflicted they are policy based
right the situation at the border what
happened in afghanistan these were
choices that were made by the biden
administration these were not things
that you know came out of the blue you
could say covet was inherited but even
on that score they have i think created
their own problems with regard to to
handling that issue so a lot of this uh
what's going on with the administration
is really self-inflicted now ben i'm
looking at
this california recall and i know people
like to say california is lost there's
no way it can ever recover
we don't know what's going to happen but
we do know kamala was there today
and we know biden's going there
apparently next week with a 39 approval
rating
what does he do for gavin newsom
in california is he truly a net positive
a few days before that recall vote
i think that's a real question laura i'm
not sure that he is i think you know
frankly you look at biden going out to
california and you kind of see
california as the test case for so many
policies that democrats want to bring
national that they want to take to the
whole country and instead what we've
seen is that in california you know the
uh the air quality is so bad and the and
the gyms are shut down you can't go
outside you can't exercise you can't
really live your life i mean california
should be the golden state it should be
something that we all aspire to it
should be a symbol of greatness for
america and instead it's an
embarrassment and i think that when you
see the the type of policies that gavin
newsom has pursued a lot of it is echoed
in what joe biden brings to the table
look we are in a tailspin moment right
now not just for joe biden but what i
think is is really true for the
democratic coalition the coalition that
he got together in 2020 including a lot
of these suburban white well-educated
women
who turned against donald trump because
of mean tweets and things like that
guess what they're the same people who
have signs talking about how much they
love refugees in front of their houses
these are the same people who are now
turning against joe biden i think you're
seeing that coalition crumble in a very
quick way and then there was some
footage tom out of california people
getting very worried
apparently about larry elder they called
him a black face of white supremacy last
week now they have someone wearing a
gorilla mask
was caught
egging
larry elder we have the video
um i'm not sure if that was a covet
approved mask tom or not but
uh they're getting they're they're
clearly not not coasting to uh september
14th in california
no no the way that that uh the media and
and folks on the ground as you just saw
i've been treating larry elder is just
reprehensible and i think that speaks to
the fact that look the fact that gavin
newsom is even in in trouble
uh in somewhat trouble right now i think
is not a good omen for the democrats and
i will just add real quickly look joe
biden his approval ratings right now in
some california is a very blue state
obviously but you look at places like
arizona where mark kelly's up for
re-election georgia uh maggie hassan in
new hampshire where joe biden's
underwater now by 10 points his approval
rating that's that is a real concern for
democrats in terms of holding on to the
house or the senate next year around if
joe biden's approval ratings don't tick
back up
joe anvil biden gentlemen thank you good
to see you tonight